الان همم
لرانيا في موسكو واحمد في واشنطن اذا ما
زلنا نتابع تداعيات هذا الاعلان من جانب
البيت الابيض همم ونريد ان نعرف المزيد هل
هناك اي معلومات اكثر من جانبي كيران يعني
نبدا معك
همم بدايه في ما يتعلقوا همم الصفقه
التبادل السجناء اخر المعطيات تشير الى ان
همم ذيك تربوت حاليا يتواجد على متن طائره
وبعد الساعات معدوده سيصل الى العاصمه
موسكو وانه تم ابلاغ عائلته
باتمان هذه الصدقه فقط اليوم بل هو اكثر
من ذلك ليلى قبل قليل
وعائله فيكتور بوت اشارت لان هذا الخبر هو
يعد افضل هديه للعائله
باختراب اعياد راس السنه في روسيا والعالم
بشكل عام اا من جهه اخرى همم هناك تصريحات
تحدثت خاصه من قبل مفاوضات حقوق الانسان
الروسيه التي اشارت لان همم يعني الفضل
بالتواصل لاتفاقيه بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا في ما يتعلق بهذه الصفقه يعود
بالدرجه الاولى لرجال الاستخبارات الهيئات
الامنيه الروسيه الخاصه التي لعبت دورا
محوريا في اتمام تنفيذ هذه الصفقه فيما
يتعلق بمساله همم المواطن الامريكي ولا ان
الذي همم ايضا هو قيد السجن في روسيا لمده
16 عاما والذي كان الحديث يدور عن امكانيه
تبديله همم
لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه مقابل الافراج
عن فيكتور بوت قبل قليل محامي الى ان اشار
في تصريحات مقتضى للغايه ان المفاوضات مع
الهيئات الامنيه الخاصه الروسيه مستمره
فيما يتعلق بامكانيه اجراء صفقات تبادل
اخرى مع السجناء مع الولايات المتحده ولكن
اشاره همم ورفض الحديث عن اي تفاصيل
اضافيه اشار الى ان كل ما يتعلق بهذه
الجزئيه هو يعني هي معطيات سريه لا يمكن
الافصاح عنها هذا في ما يتعلق همم يعني
اخر تطورات ولكن من جهه اخرى همم يعني
هناك بالفعل ترحيب في الاوساط الروسيه
بهذه الخطوه فيكتور بوت شخصيه معروفه جدا
في الاوساط الروسيه مشهوره جدا وهنا ود
التذكير بانه حتى على المستوى الاجتماعي
على المستوى الشعبي اا خلال الاعوام
الماضيه خاصه عندما تم اعتقاله ومن ثم
محاكمته في تلك المراحل كانت هناك همم
يعني تظاهرات مؤيده لفيكتور بوت همم في
العاصمه موسكو بما في ذلك امام السفاره
الامريكيه وعليه فان همم يعني همم اسلام
هذه الصفقه هي يعني بيحاسب بوسائل الاعلام
هي يعني يمكن القول انه نجاح بالنسبه
للجانب الروسي الاساسيه او انه تم
استبدالته استبداله يعني يعني وفقا
للمعطيات المتحده ليست مقابل شخصين
امريكيين مواطنين امريكيين بل مقابل مواطن
واحد وهو فيكتور من اخرى ايضا اشارت
السلطات الرسميه اا
مفوضيه حقوق الانسان وما الى ذلك الا ان
همم فيكتور بوت وايضا لعبه كره السله
الامريكيه جرينار لن يقومان
باتمان عقوبه السجن في بلادهما في بلديهما
فور وصولهما اذ ان السلطات الامريكيه قامت
بالعفو عن فيكتور بوت وفي المقابل السلطات
الروسيه هي الاخرى قامت بالعفو همم لاعبه
كره السله الامريكيه
اذا لا السجن لا في الولايات المتحده
لجراينر ولا في روسيا لابوت احمد هزيم
ال ال الاعلام الروسي صور الامر على انه
انتصار لرجال المخابرات الروسيه
والاستخبارات الروسيه كيف يصوره ويتوقع ان
يصوره الاعلام الامريكي
المستقطم ما بين اعلام ليبرالي واعلام
محافظ وقليل من الاعلام المستقل
نعم
تتباين هنا في الولايات المتحده على هذه
الصفقه وعلى الحديث الرئيس في خطاب الرئيس
الامريكي
قبل قليل هناك من انتقد كما انتقل الضيف
الامريكي همم سيد ريتشارد قبل قليل على
شاشه الجزيره انتقد هذه الصفقه في القول
بان كان على الاداره ان تصر على الافراج
بالعرض الذي قدم منذ البدايه لروسيا
بالافراج عن
بولويلانر مقابل تسليم روسيا فيكتور لكن
هناك ايضا من يرى بانه سيكون من الصعب على
الرئيس الامريكي من الناحيه الانسانيه
والقول لهم بان عليها ان تبقى في السجون
الروسيه
وتكمل حكمها هناك لان لانه ليس من من همم
المناسب سياسيه للاداره الامريكيه ان لا
تتم الصفقه دون الافراج عن بولندا فهذه
الاراء همم
راح الان على وسائل الام الامريكيه لكن
بالنسبه
للشاعر على الامريكي بالنسبه للناقل
الامريكي الافراج عن همم
بريتنير وهي لاعب الكره السله وغرام
المواطنين الامريكيين بالمشاهير سيكون
لصالح الرئيس الامريكي حسب ما يقول البعض
فيما يرجح اخرون ان بقاء بولن في سجون
الروسيه لمده اطول دون الوصول الى صفقه
تبادل الاخرى للسجناء تطلق صراحه وربما قد
تؤثر على الرئيس الامريكي سياسيا الحساب
هنا على الحساب الامريكي الانساني السياسي
انسانيا الرئيس قام بعمل جيد سياسيا هناك
من ينتقده بانه ترك بورويلا وعطا روسيا
صفقه صبت لصالحه همم احمد كنت تحدثت سابقا
عن التغيير في الكوميرس الامريكي والقياده
الجمهوريه المتوقعه ليه همم مجلس النواب
وموقفها من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا انها
ان الدعم ليس شيكا العالم بياض
ما المتوقع ان يتغير
هي تصريحات كيفما كارثي وهو زعيم زعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب ويتوقع ان يكون
رئيسا لمجلس النواب عندما يتسلم
الجمهوريون الاغلبيه هناك تصريحات كررها
اكثر من مره بالقول بان
الدعم لاوكرانيا لن يكون مفتوحا دون حدود
وهو استجابه لبعض الضغوط التي يتعرض لها
من اقصى اليمين ضمن كتلته الانتخابيه في
مجلس النواب والذين يرفعون باتجاه وقف
الدعم لاوكرانيا بشكل كلي ويريد ان يسعى
الى الاثنين اصواتهم لكي يفوز او يحصل على
موقع رئيس مجلس النواب ذلك ربما يدفع بهذا
الاتجاه هناك من يرى في هذه التصريحات
بعدا اخر خصوصا انها تتزامن مع تصريحات
مسؤولين في الاداره الحاليه وهي الاداره
الديمقراطيه اداره رئيس استمعنا الى مارك
ميلي الجنرال الامريكي الذي قال بان على
اوكرانيا الان ان تبدا عمليه التفاوض بعد
ما حققته على الارض من تقدم خلال همم
الاسابيع الماضيه هناك تسريبات في وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه بالقول بان الجمهوريين
انتم مسكوا مجلس النواب او ان تسلموا
اغلبيه في مجلس النواب انهم قد يعرقلون اي
تمويلات اضافيه الى اوكرانيا وهذا ايضا
يشكل ضغطا على القياده هناك في الكيف
عندما تجري حساباتها مننا قد لا تستطيع او
خلتمكن من استلام مساعدات عسكريه ضخمه
امريكيه من من واشنطن في حال تمكن
الجمهوريه من اعاقه اي تمويل اضافي حتى
اللحظه هناك 40 مليار دولار تم اقرارها في
الكونغرس لتمويل همم تسليم اوكرانيا معدات
عسكريه وحتى معدات همم متعلقه بشان
الانساني سورفا منها 19 مليار دولار
الاداره لا تزال تحظى بمخزون كبير من
التمويل للاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا عسكريه
وانسانيه وماديا واقتصاديا ااه خلال
الاشهر الماضيه لكن هذه التصريحات وهذا
الجو العام خصوصا مع
ظهور ان هناك فوتور في التاييد لدى
الناخبين الامريكيين للاستمرار بدعم
اوكرانيا بلا افق في استطلاعات الراي وين
كانت الاغربيه لا تزال مع دعم اوكرانيا في
هذه الحرب عندما ليست اغلبيه كبيره جدا
كما كان الامر بعبدايه هذه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا هذا الاتجاه لدى المواطنين
الامريكيين حسب استطلاعات الراي بعض
التصريحات التي تظهر او تخرج العالم بين
ليله واخرى بعض التسريبات التي تنقلها
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه على ان هناك ضغوط
تمارسها الاداره او تحسن من قبل اداره على
اليد
فتح مجال لروسيا لكي لكي تهيئ الظروف الى
الدخول في عمليه تفوضيه كل هذا يصب نوعا
ما ضغطا على القياده هناك في اوكرانيا
وعلى اطلاعها على هذه التقارير بلا الشيك
وعلى هذه التصريحات همم يجعلها تعيد
الحساب مره اخرى في الى اي مدى يمكنها
الاعتماد على الدعم الغربي المطلق خصوصا
وان هذا الدعم الغربي المطلق تقوده
الولايات المتحده وتقوده اداره بادن
تحديدا اا لكي لاي مدى يمكن لكيام
الاعتماد على هذا هذه هذا الدعم دون ان
يكون لديها استعداد للدخول في مفاوضات
خصوصا وان شروط الحكومه الاوكرانيه رحيل
الرئيس بوتين وخروج جميع القوات الروسيه
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه همم هي شروط همم
صارمه للغايه هناك من يرى في الداخل
الامريكي بانها شروط الجنسيه